real men of genius  [Music]  today reason TV salutes you mister  plagiarizing gaffe prone hair plug  wearing vice president you turned  against the Iraq war but you've dropped  more bombs than george w bush my memory  is not as good as justice roberts you're  the perfect opening act for a president  wants to look good by comparison and  you're never afraid to call a spade a  spade when you're not pretending to eat  at places that close 20 years ago you're  pretending that other people's words are  your own when you're not creating the  drug czars office you're talking crazy  is all [ __ ]  it's good to know that the Vice  President is an evil anymore just dumber  than Dan Quayle Chuck Graham state  senators here Chucky stand up Chuck let  him see you Oh God love you what am I  talking about  [Music]